der große streit um die letzten
deutschen atomkraftwerke dieser streit
ist das politische thema dieser woche
denen die regierung sie zerlegt sich
gegenseitig in diesem atomkraft streit
und sie hat noch mal richtig öl ins
feuer gegossen in diesem streit ricarda
lang die grünen-chefin sie schließt ein
wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft jetzt
nämlich kategorisch aus rumms und das
während der andere teil der regierung
gerade diesen wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft vorbereitet christian lindner
der fdp chef und bundesfinanzminister
er hat ja das gesagt zur möglichen
verlängerung der akw-laufzeiten vieles
spricht dafür die sicheren und
klimafreundlichen kernkraftwerke nicht
abzuschalten sondern nötigenfalls bis 20
24 zu nutzen und jetzt eben die antwort
der grünen co chefin ricarda lang das
hat sie am abend im zdf gesagt
das was die anbieter will ist nichts
anderes als der wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft und das wird es mit uns auf
jeden fall nicht geben ich finde
manchmal dass wir eine etwas unernst
heftigkeit in dieser debatte haben dafür
dass immer noch über eine
hochrisikotechnologie sprechen viele
menschen machen sich sorgen mit blick
auf winter und im blick auf den herbst
was die gas versorgen was die
energieversorgung angeht und gerade weil
diese sorgen dass sind sind wir ist
glaube ich verpflichtet den menschen
antworten zu geben die auch tatsächlich
zum problemen passen also das zu tun was
wirklich hilft aber das lassen was
eigentlich nicht möglich ist ein klares
nein ein kategorisches nein der grünen
co chef amerikaner lang zum
wiedereinstieg in die atomkraft und das
in dieser energiekrise im jahr 2022
[Musik]